today we're gonna look at the bishop and
we're gonna see how much is worth how it
moves and how to take advantage of a
good bishop in a bad bishop in a game
first thing you want to know is Bishop
is worth three pawns in a game it's
equivalent to a knight but they move
very differently we're gonna go over the
benefits of each but first thing you
wanna know is how Bishop moves the new
bishop moves diagonally so as you can
see a bishop can cover a lot of ground
on a chessboard especially in an open
game open game meaning there's not a lot
blocking the bishop now you can tell big
difference between this setup and then
let's say we put pawns in front of the
bishop and just see the difference that
it makes so let's say we put pawns on b5
and d5 you can already tell a big
difference and the movement that the
bishop can make now the bishop before he
could move all over the board but now he
can only move a very limited space so
bishops really work well in open games
meaning there's not a lot of pawns
blocking or even pieces for that matter
blocking but more importantly pawns if
you have a setup where their pawns all
over the board it's really even though
you may have both your bishops but let's
just take a look at this example here if
you have pawns everywhere especially on
light squares well you cannot get to
your opponent you can't get past your
pawns ever until you start moving your
pawns forward so right now this bishop
is really limited in its space so you
want to make sure if you have bishops
that you give the bishop room so
knew so many times people make a mistake
early on especially in the beginning of
the game even before anything else is
they may make a move like f3 is their
first move will this blocks off their
night and it blocks off their Bishop is
blocked off from eat for moving can't
move past the e2 pond and it can move
past the g2 pond more commonly you'll
see a move at the beginning you'll see
something like e4 or d4 and what this
does is it opens up lanes for your
Bishop to move and you always want to
have lanes for your Bishop to move
because again as we said bishops work
really well on long diagonals and if
they don't have long diagonals to work
with it's really not going to be
beneficial and you're not going to get
the best use out of your fish so make
sure especially later on that your pawns
aren't blocking your bishop and if you
have a lot of pawns you want to make
sure that they're not on the same square
as your bishop so if you have a light
square bishop you want to make sure that
your pawns are on dark square Bishop so
you can move around your pawns you don't
want your pawns to be blocking your own
bishops early on when your pawns are
moving around it doesn't matter as much
as long as your bishop can move but
later on in the middle stage and later
on in the game towards the endgame you
want to make sure that your bishops are
not locked in so this is how the bishops
work hopefully it helped use it in your
own game